effectivement la nouvelle nous a été
confirmé dans l'après midi par le
parquet de mâcon
les corps d'une femme et de deux enfants
ont été repêchés aujourd'hui dans le
canal du centre près de ciry le noble où
je me trouve ces trois corps se
trouvaient au fond du canal dans une
petite robe saxo grise dont la plaque
d'immatriculation correspond à ce
véhicule qui était recherché depuis le
28 janvier dernier et la disparition
inexpliquée de sophie zizou tôt 39 ans
et ses deux enfants liam et yumi 7 et 3
ans l'identité de ces trois corps est
encore à confirmer mais elle ne laisse
guère de doute ce soir
cette découverte met fin à presque deux
mois de recherche pour retrouver cette
mère de famille et ses deux enfants
il y avait eu des recherches aériennes
mais surtout aquatique presque tous les
jours en fonction de la météo et des
effectifs
le plan de recherche consistait à
s'éloigner au fur et à mesure du
domicile jusqu'à ce plan d'eau donc de
ciry le noble
depuis ce matin une quinzaine de
personnes étaient mobilisées notamment
la brigade fluviale de saint jean de
losne et des plongeurs qui ont fait très
attention à préserver les corps en vue
de l' autopsie
demain un point presse du parquet de
mâcon est prévu pour faire toute la
lumière sur cette macabre découverte